anticipation is high of the return of
daredevil next month especially since
the Punisher is set to play a major role
in the Marvel show's second season I'm
Dave and welcome to you're punishing
gamespot nudes update it has now been
reported the netflix is planning a
spin-off show to focus on the vigilante
fan favorite according to Variety sister
site TVLine Netflix is so happy with
John bertles portrayal of the vengeful
gun-toting Frank Castle that they are
very close to commissioning a standalone
show a Punisher series would become the
sixth Marvel show the channel has
developed the others include Jessica
Jones which was recently renewed for a
second season and luke cage which will
debut later this year plus the in the
works iron fist and the defenders in an
interview with DW this week birth will
discuss taking on the role of Frank
Castle who becomes the Punisher after
the murder of his family it's an
important character it's one I'm honored
to play this is a guy who means a lot to
a lot of people and his character has
resonance with law enforcement and
military people have been coming up to
me in the streets of New York saying do
not mess this up what was important was
the emptiness inside him he's dealing
with this unbelievable loss it's
unbelievable anger and hatred and shame
there's a sense of responsibility and as
a father and husband I had to put myself
in his dark of place as possible in the
last six months it's going to be a
special season if you thought the last
season of daredevil was dark we're going
to a whole new place so we were excited
to see Frank Castle back on your screens
let us know in the comments section
below or you can find me on Twitter at a
regular Dave and for all your Marvel
news stay tuned to gamespot com